- [Voiceover] The range of colors
that homeowners could use on
the exterior of their houses
was blank by the
community's stringent rules
regarding upkeep of property.
So we're talking about the range of colors
that homeowners could use on
the exterior of their house.
And it was blank by the
community's stringent rules.
So stringent rules,
that means strict rules.
They're not gonna allow
a lot of range of colors.
They're going to be very, maybe, specific
or they're going to try to limit
the number of colors that
you might want to use.
That's the way I'm thinking of this.
Now let's look at the choices.
So the first one is circumscribed,
which means putting boundaries
on things, limiting things.
That seems in line with
having stringent rules.
The range of colors that
homeowners could use
on the exterior of their
houses was circumscribed
by the community's stringent rules
regarding upkeep of property.
That actually feels pretty good,
so I'm gonna go with this one for now.
They were trying to put restraints on
or putting limits or putting boundaries
which is what circumscribed means.
Stringent rules would essentially
circumscribe the range of colors.
That makes sense.
Let's look at these other choices.
The range of colors that
homeowners could use
on the exterior of their houses
was bolstered by the
community's stringent rules.
Well no, stringent rules
aren't going to bolster,
they're not going to boost
the number of colors.
They're not going to
give you more options.
They're probably going to
give you fewer options.
So let's rule that one out.
The range of colors was embellished
by the community's stringent rules?
No, once again,
embellishing means to add more,
to kind of put some frills on it,
to make it a little bit more exciting
if we're talking about
embellishing a story.
So stringent rules are not going to
embellish a range of colors,
they're going to restrict
a range of colors.
They're not going to make
it even more exciting,
more flowery, more options.
So the range of colors was insinuated
by the community's stringent rules?
Insinuating means you're
implying something,
you're hinting at something
without really saying it directly.
Now stringent rules seem
like the type of rules
that they wouldn't try
beat around the bush.
They would just get to the point.
They wouldn't try to insinuate things.
They wouldn't just try to hint.
They would be very specific about
"Look, this is what you can
do and what you can't do."
So I don't think community stringent rules
would try to insinuate a range of colors,
they would just tell you,
"Look, you're either
gonna do this or that,
"this is allowed, this is not allowed."
That's what makes them
stringent, very strict rules.
The range of colors was cultivated
by the community's stringent rules.
Well once again cultivated means
that you're helping to kind of develop.
You're cultivating a garden,
you're really fostering it,
you're giving it nutrition,
you're really trying to
make something blossom.
And once again, stringent rules,
that doesn't seem like something that
would try to cultivate a range of colors.
"Hey let's try and think of more colors.
"Let's make sure we've thought
of all the colors possible
and all of the rest."
That doesn't make a lot of sense
that stringent rules would try to do that.